mobile task forces the renowned first
line of defense for the SCP Foundation
comprised of the organization's most
highly trained operatives mtfs are the
boots on the ground dealing with
anomalous threats and containment
breaches head on it's a dangerous job in
fact joining an MTF is widely considered
one of the most hazardous roles within
the entire Foundation one where every
day brings with it a whole host of
unexpected threats and a high number of
casualties so let's take a look at how
one of those days goes 6 A.M
and troops comes a gravel voice yell
louder than any alarm clock the very
second that early morning call goes out
over the intercom the members of MTF new
7 are on their feet climbing out of
their bunks and quickly getting into
uniform The Operators file out of their
barracks and hastily make their way to
the mess hall among them is the latest
recruit to join this particular task
force private Killian Hess lines up to
receive his breakfast behind his new
Squad mates this all takes place before
most of the foundation has even woken up
even though these MTF operatives would
rely on working as a team to keep each
other alive there is little casual
conversation most of them are actually
quite solemn as they eat aware of the
inherent risk that comes with their job
private Hess receiving a briefing the
previous day is paired with a more
grizzled and much older veteran of news
7. Lieutenant Patterson upon sitting
next to his new senior officer Hess
immediately asks what has the rest of
the unit feeling so
boy you really all knew Patterson scoffs
look rookie we do what we do and watch
each other's backs like good soldiers
but make no mistake you're on the USS
Enterprise now kid and one of the red
shirts 8 am following their breakfast
and early start any MTF operatives that
aren't thrust into immediate action are
sent to their designated basic training
area here they are presented with all
manner of intense assault courses
fighting rings for hand-to-hand sparring
and a live ammo shooting range to
improve skills with weapon proficiency
the SCP Foundation demands the highest
level of skill from its mobile task
forces so regular combat drills are an
absolute necessity for keeping their
operators alert and ready to take on all
manner of threats for some of the more
hot-headed MTF troops drills are a
chance to cut loose show off their
skills or challenge their squad mates to
beat each other's fastest assault course
times or shooting range scores but to
those that have been around longer and
have the benefit of hindsight after
multiple catastrophic containment
breaches morning training can feel like
pretty inadequate preparation after all
the foundation sends its mtfs to take on
some of their most dangerous scps most
of which have wild unpredictable
abilities how does practicing Krav Maga
really help prepare someone for a fight
with a creature that can warp reality
around it and hitting motionless paper
targets at a range can seem a little
redundant when some anomalies are
virtually bulletproof 10 a.m of course
this is the SCP Foundation meaning it
doesn't take long for some strange
happening to occur MTF News 7 are soon
dispatched on their first assignment
after the foundation loses contact with
a site known to house a particularly
dangerous anomaly nicknamed hammerdown
the task force Hess has found himself
thrust into is usually deployed as a
direct result of incidents where
communication is lost with Foundation
facilities and containment breaches are
suspected to have occurred hopping
aboard high-speed transport private Hess
and the rest of hammerdown are quickly
briefed on their mission at
approximately 0 900 hours the same day
the foundation lost contact with another
pair of their mtfs Omega 59 AKA
nacheva's wolves and Sigma 18 the Chess
Masters both were stationed at armed
containment complex zero four a secure
location within the Russian federation's
sakha Republic Patterson informs the
rest of MTF News 7 that they were to
re-establish communication with the site
and assess any potential danger although
by the time the transport arrives at
complex zero four it becomes pretty
clear that things aren't looking good
scp-1984 has breached containment the
Dead Hand is loose unluckily for hammer
down
scp-1984 is a semi-corporeal entity with
a nasty habit of attacking any human
being that it comes into contact with by
disrupting their nervous systems usually
resulting in excruciating pain although
that did answer the question of what had
happened to the other mtfs at the site
12pm immediately engaging the Dead Hand
hammer down stormed complex 0-4
Patterson had ordered them to go weapons
haunt on the Creature from the moment
the transport touched down having
manifested as a hazy humanoid outline
scp-1984 was making quick work of
slaughtering MTF Omega 59 and sigma 18.
new 7 were able to intercept before it
could completely decimate their fellow
operatives but now the Dead Hand had
them pinned stopping the unit from
accessing the on-site Armory well they
had all arrived loaded for bear the MTF
operatives knew they couldn't keep
scp-1984 at Bay for long with only their
standard issue Conventional Weapons the
entities only known weakness was
microwave radiation that could be
emitted using specialized weapons if
only they could access the complex zero
four Armory times of the essence 2 and
the pressure of stopping scp-1984
quickly weighs heavily on private Hess
he and the rest of hammerdown know how
the entity operates that it would be
heading just over 80 kilometers
Northwest at the first chance it got if
one too many of them were killed or if
there was a pause in the fighting for a
second too long the Dead Hand would be
on its way to an installation nearby
housing a number of intercontinental
ballistic missiles once there it would
waste no time interfacing with nuclear
command systems launching those icbms
and causing catastrophic destruction 1
30 PM deploying some quick thinking
Lieutenant Patterson contacted
Foundation command and had them send a
secondary Detachment of new 7 to the
missile installation part of their
mobile task force includes a platoon of
experts in various forms of warfare not
just chemical and biological but nuclear
too well that portion of hammerdown were
directed to lock down the missile
installation 80 kilometers away
Patterson Hess and the rest of new 7
were trying to distract
scp-1984. their engagement lasted around
an hour with the entity attacking an
number of the troops on the ground each
one would suffer symptoms of intense
neurological trauma including seizures
and the loss of cerebral spinal fluid
from their nose and eyes experiencing it
was painful enough and the sight of his
fellow MTF agents dying in such a
horrific fashion wasn't exactly what
private Hess expected from his first day
eventually scp-1984 dissipates after a
sustained battle with hammerdown
although it could easily re-manifest if
it ever intercepts particular broadcasts
but the task Force's work at complex
zero four is far from over after the
battle comes the cleanup operation
private Hess follows orders from
Patterson to clear as much debris and as
many bodies as he can making a note of
every member of their unit that they
lost to the Dead Hand however it doesn't
take long for the surviving members of
new 7 to receive another call for
assistance 4pm despite hess's concerns
that he and the others haven't eaten in
hours the team loads up and heads out
again the foundation is sent word that
someone has taken advantage of all the
commotion at complex zero four and
forced their way into a different site
wasting no time the remainder of
hammerdown dusted off from the Sakai
Republic locking and loading ready to
begin their next mission arriving at the
site Foundation command radios to new
seven updating them about their
situation A large group of assailants
all members of the Church of the broken
God was midway through launching an
assault against the SCP Foundation their
goal was unclear although the site they
had targeted was known to house
scp-882 this anomaly is widely believed
to be the heart of the broken God a
deity worshiped by those of the
mechanist faith one of the church's core
goals was to repair their God as well as
to enhance themselves through mechanical
anomalous means of course this means
that a group of cyborg cultists awaited
the arriving task force hammerdon
clashes with the Church of the broken
God trying to divert them away from the
saltwater tank containing scp-880 2.
Lieutenant Patterson warns them not to
get too close to the mass of welded
metal noting that the mtf's troops
weapons would become fused to scp-882 if
so hearing that is what gives Hess the
idea to engage the Cyborg's hand to hand
although the church members were much
stronger luring them closer to the heart
of the broken God meant all their
metallic enhancements would also become
pulled into
scp-882 killing the devoted cultists
despite how pleased they were to become
one with their God McCain 7 PM moments
of levity are often rare for mobile task
forces already it's been a hell of a day
multiple deployments and extremely high
casualties for private Hess exhaustion
is already setting in he's been awake
for over 12 hours barely survived
encounters with a hostile SCP and a
tenacious group of interest and during
each of the ensuing battles he has been
made to watch as a number of his fellow
operatives die some of them he'd only
just met now he can barely recall their
name times instead as the day draws to a
close he prays that he Lieutenant
Patterson and the dwindling remains of
their squad won't be called on again but
this is the SCP Foundation after all 8
pm and whatever can go wrong usually
does with a gigantic angry reptile in
the middle of it sure enough the alarms
begin to sound and private Hess has to
get back to his feet he musters what
fading scraps of energy he can will back
into his being his weapon feeling
heavier than it has all day a tiny Spike
of adrenaline hits as Patterson barks
the Fateful words Hess had hoped he
would never hear on your feet Soldier
scp-682 is loose hammer down races
through the facility corridors passed by
a flood of researchers all fleeing for
their lives the MTF team reaches the
containment chamber just in time to
witness
scp-682 the infamous hard to destroy
reptile lunging at the unfortunate
Personnel that couldn't get away in time
right next to Hess one of his fellow new
seven teammates steps in a puddle of
acid that has spilled from the vet that
usually houses the murderous reptilian
monster as the carnivorous scp-682
finishes decimating its previous Target
it turns to angrily charge for the MTF
troops who raise their weapons and open
fire in what is ultimately a futile
attempt at stopping a creature that
can't be harmed by mere bullets 10 p.m
hours pass containment breaches by
scp-682 are far from an uncommon
occurrence and fortunately the
foundation's task forces are more than
used to driving the creature back into
its acid tank where it's held only
slightly more securely but with every
escape attempt by the hard to destroy
reptile comes a slew of casualties from
Foundation personnel and today is no
exception despite having sustained heavy
injuries himself Lieutenant Patterson is
instructed by a superiors to file an
end-of-day report before he and those
that are still breathing can be
debriefed the MTF lieutenantalia up the
considerable losses his unit sustained
on their various engagements throughout
the day every operative killed by the
dead hand then those that the Church of
the broken God were able to make quick
work of and of course the ones who met
their demise at the hands or rather jaws
of
scp-682 the role of a mobile task force
operative is a difficult and dangerous
job but what few realize is how
Expendable these troops are to the
foundation in fact they're not all that
different from d-class in that regard
the SCP Foundation will simply throw
their most skilled agents Into The Fray
in hopes that enough of them will kill
or contain an anomalous threat no matter
how many lives it costs perhaps nothing
exemplifies that more than the body of
private Killian Hess being wheeled away
for disposal after falling in battle
with scp-682 as if dying on his first
day wasn't bad enough the superior
officers of MTF News 7 are already
looking for a replacement to join hammer
down if this sounds like fun to you
apply today now then Rocky go and check
out SCP Elite Mobile task force
explained and how to work at the SCP
Foundation explained for more of the ins
and outs of working for the SCP
Foundation